la explosión ocurrió en este café de San
Petersburgo y fue registrada por las
cámaras de seguridad el objetivo el
popular blogger o militar ruso ladlene
tatarsky fervente defensor de la
invasión de Ucrania el hombre murió al
instante una superviviente de los hechos
contó que fue una mujer quien introdujo
el explosivo al local oculto en una
estatuilla
la estatuilla de la cabeza de un minero
con un casco la colocaron en alguna
parte de atrás y sin prestarle mucha
atención vladenta tarsky continuó
conversando y de repente todo explotó y
se llenó de humo
una mujer fue arrestada por los hechos
la sospechosa identificada como daria
trepova reconoció su responsabilidad
entiende porque está detenida por estar
en el lugar donde vladdensky ha sido
asesinado Qué hizo usted
llevar la estatuilla donde explotó
quién le dio la estatuilla se lo puedo
decir después
las autoridades investigan el móvil de
los hechos el comité investigativo ruso
en cooperación con la policía detuvo a
dar y a trepó a bajo sospecha de estar
involucrada en la explosión en un café
de San Petersburgo el proceso de
investigación está en marcha estamos
tratando de identificar el motivo del
crimen y los investigadores decidirán la
forma en que queda detenida
según Fuentes citadas por medios rusos
la dentatas que conocía a la detenida en
cuestión la noche de la explosión fue
para participar en un acto organizado
por un grupo nacionalista flat
lentatarsky El bloguero ruso asesinado
llamado maxim fomi en realidad tenía más
de medio millón de seguidores en
Telegram este video filmado en el
kremlin fue de los más populares
venceremos a todo el mundo mataremos a
todo el mundo haremos explotar todo el
mundo si es necesario Dios está con
nosotros
que combatió en 2014 con las milicias
prorrusas en el donbas el kremlin ya ha
calificado el asesinato de un atentado
terrorista y apunta a la autoría de
agentes u